[Music]
there's no mistaking
the sound of pollution
but even as the black exhaust cloud
dissipates it doesn't really disappear
leaving an indelible mark in the memory
of mark bedard
i'm running in the morning and sometimes
i i have one of those you know
old diesel school buses in front of me
and i i can hardly breathe ironic given
that when bedard
founded lion bus in 2008 the diesel
engine was the beast that made his buses
go
his company grew and became profitable
but those fumes lingered
bedard would become inspired by the
potential for
electric buses and trucks even gave a
speech on it six years ago
and for you know 20-25 minutes i was
telling the people yeah it's possible
but everybody was questioning if it's
possible
even if they didn't believe it only
mattered that he did
those diesel machines were contemporary
dinosaurs
and it was only a matter of time before
they became fossils
today his school buses have a range of
400 kilometers
and can recharge in as little as a few
hours
what we were saying at lyon is that if
we don't do it now
at some point it's going to be too late
and then the people were saying well
yeah but is it too early
say well maybe 10 years ago it was too
early
his timing appears to have been spot on
his company now renamed lion electric
is shaking up the industry signing big
deals with the likes of amazon and ikea
lion's high voltage roar makes for a
busy shop floor
in fact bedard's challenge quickly went
from having people accept the concept of
electric buses and trucks
to having enough space to meet demand
the numbers speak for themselves
a planned u.s expansion will increase
output
from 3 000 to 23 000 vehicles per year
even beyond lions shop walls in the
quaint town of san jerome just outside
montreal
things are changing too lion offers
anyone access to a charging station in
its parking lot
and they're all occupied
the ev1 is gm's first totally electric
non-combustible fuel fuel-on-board
passenger vehicle
a decade or two ago consumers looked at
electric vehicles or evs
as a curiosity
today they're turning heads as much for
appeal as necessity
because canadians need a spark in fact
our love of suvs and pickups helped
raise overall emissions from
transportation
about 30 percent over the last 20 years
more evs on the road will mean
reductions in co2 not only from
transportation but also on the main
source of emissions
oil and gas production comparing the
impact of evs versus combustion engines
is the main focus of these university of
toronto researchers
professor heather mclean has crunched
the numbers
we showed essentially that we'd have to
have
about 90 percent of electric vehicles in
the fleet by 2050
to to meet the the targets of the paris
agreement postdoctoral researcher
alexandre milivanov knows
the question really is when will
canadians turn their backs on the roar
of the internal combustion engine
for the hum of electric so i think
they're getting ready
they could push harder but i think there
is also the chicken egg problem right
if you don't have the evs on the road
does it make really sense to invest that
much infrastructures but if you don't
have the infrastructures does it make
sense to buy an eevee
and around and around we go to even buy
an ev in canada
is made more difficult by the fact in
2021
70 of dealerships don't have models on
the floor
again it's the chicken and the egg so
how do we catch up
well price is an ongoing issue even with
government rebates
evs are still more expensive than their
gas counterparts
and then there's what's known as range
anxiety
high-end models top out around 600
kilometers
more than most people would need on any
given day but the fear
of running out of juice remains although
battery technology
is improving at a rapid pace by 2030
most of the reports are estimating that
they're going to be probably twice more
energy dense what does that mean it
means for the same mass
you'll have twice more energy getting
out of it and will our energy grid be
able to handle it
eventually yes says joanna curiosis of
clean energy canada which looks at how
to make the shift to clean tech
and renewable energy i think you know if
all of a sudden we were
going to increase the number of evs on
the road by
200 percent tomorrow then then no we're
not going to be ready
but if we put the policies and plans in
place
to make this shift happen in a
predictable way
then then yeah electric utilities can
make those infrastructure upgrades where
needed
another big challenge how we redesign
our cities for the eevee revolution
consider some of montreal's more densely
packed neighborhoods like the plateau
where residents are always moving their
cars around to accommodate street
parking lots
or toronto's west end with its narrow
streets in high density
eighty percent of all ev owners plug
their cars in at night
but what if you don't have a driveway
those people and homes are referred to
as garage orphans and
you're absolutely right we need a
solution for them
charge stations exist even though they
aren't everywhere but it's not nearly as
fast as gassing up your car
beyond the unlikely scenario of tearing
everything down to build back up
ideas like mass charging stations at
postal outlets or
mandating charging stations at
workplaces are being bandied about
there's also a move to community
charging hubs so
you know maybe it's a community center
or an elementary school
in your neighborhood that can have a
bunch of charging stations installed and
then people can park there overnight
plug in and leave in the morning the
honorable member for
windsor west windsor mp brian massey has
been flying the ev
flag for over a decade he's seen his
share of the ups and downs in the auto
sector
and worries canada is in danger of
missing out on the benefits of an
entirely new manufacturing economy
i don't like the strategies of waiting
around and figuring it out later on
or leaving it to others where he sees
opportunity isn't something canada has
in abundance the rare metals that go
into ev batteries
notably lithium and it might surprise
you but a new democrat
and an environmentalist believe canada
needs to get more
into the mining game
we have to be cognizant though that
there is some other
costs for this that there is a upfront
cost to the innovation
and there's also some environmental
costs that are a little bit different
but if we build them into the plan we
bake them into the system we can
actually use it to advantage if not
we're going to give it up to somebody
else
and that's not right that doesn't make
any sense we've been pushing for the
same thing
the metals and mineral resources that we
have
they they do help canada bring some
bargaining chips to the table
for massey who like his father once
worked in windsor's auto factories
it goes beyond retooling the grid and
auto sector
it's about ensuring canada has a seat at
the eb table
i think that we have to say we want to
be a nation of builders whether it be an
automotive whether it be in
manufacturing in the wood
in the agricultural sector in many
respects with some of the innovation
taking place there
it's what lion electric's mark bedard
said when he began transforming his
company
now he can say with pride that he's
doing what was previously
inconceivable for a canadian automotive
startup
signing big deals with the biggest
companies and expanding his operations
into the us when we see that the world
is changing
the full ecosystem is is is
changing and right now and uh and and
this is
i think this is this is awesome this is
great